All right. Hello,
everybody. My name is
Shivani Fardala. I am
one of the academic
medicine scholars
here at NYIT, and
I'm going to be giving
you guys a series
of two lectures.
This is the first one
all about bipolar and
depressive disorders.
I worked on this
lecture extensively
with Dr. Corey Dyson
out in Arkansas.
So thank you so much
for your guidance
on this project. And
without any further
ado, we're going to
jump right into it.
So here are your
session objectives for
today. Basically, what
we're going to be doing
is going through all
of the main disorders
that are going to
pop up on your USMLE
and your complex
exams, comparing and
contrasting them
using the official
DSM-5 diagnostic
criteria. We're
going to go through
the etiology and
epidemiology of these
depressive and bipolar
disorders, list some of
the common differential
diagnoses that you
might come up with
when encountering these
diseases in the hospital,
and then describe
the evidence-based
assessments and treatment
approaches for each
disorder as well.
So quick note before
we get started,
you do not need to
memorize every single
thing that is in
this PowerPoint.
So what I want you to
do is focus really on
a lot of the topics
that have this little
blue star right there
that will clue you
into exactly what you
need to know. So the
goal is not to memorize
all of these little
details. It's to
understand the overall
clinical picture so
that you can effectively
synthesize a diagnosis
in your head and feel
more prepared when
answering questions on
the material so before
we jump into some of
the pathophysiology and
the actual diagnosis
let's take a look at
two clinical cases
um of two patients that
are presenting with
depression but
showing very different
symptoms so for our
first case here we have
nami 35 year old female
presenting to the
clinic with complaints
of feeling down she
reports a two to three
month history of low
mood poor concentration
at work tearful episodes
low energy feelings
of guilt and shame
and a listlessness which
is uncharacteristic
of her she denies
any suicidal thoughts
but reports unintentional
weight loss of 10
pounds right now let's
compare and contrast
these symptoms to our
next clinical case
all right and in this
case here we have
luffy 52 year old male
presenting with complaints
of just feeling
off they note a six
-month history of anhedonia
scattered thoughts
a short temper and random
emotional outbursts
which have been
greatly affecting their
daily life they've
begun overeating due to
stress and they note
a 15 pound weight
gain they avoid eye
contact when talking and
their affect appears
flat they deny thoughts
of hurting themselves
or others but state
that they have attempted
to take their own
life once in the past
when they were 20
years old. So even just
at a glance, you can
see that both of these
patients, and I'll
tell you guys right
now, they are both
suffering from some
type of depression, but
their clinical presentation
varies dramatically.
So it's really
important to have a good
mental heuristic of
the different ways that
depression can present
in your patients.
So keeping that in
mind, what medical
problems can mimic some
depressive disorders?
So I'll give you
guys a second
to kind of answer
this question.
And here we go. All
of the above is the
correct answer here. So
things from hypothyroidism
to substance *****,
low vitamin D, anemia,
low vitamin B12, all
of these things can
mimic depressive disorders.
So before we make
a judgment or try to
put together a diagnosis
on what was going on
with our first two
patients here, those
clinical cases we need
to rule out any additional
medical problems
before we make a
psychiatric diagnosis okay
so quick clinical
pearl you're going to
want to keep this in
mind for all mental
health disorders
especially when
answering questions
on your exams you must
rule out other medical
conditions first
we don't know whether
or not these symptoms
are from a true
depression or if they're
depressive symptoms
due to some other
medical condition
that the patient may
have. So in other
words, if your symptoms
are not better
accounted by another
underlying medical
condition, then we can
move on to making a
psychiatric diagnosis.
So again, this is
just a quick little
differential that you
could put together for some
depressive symptoms
that you might see in
questions or in your
patients in real life
in the hospital. And
really, it's less
about memorizing this
list and more about just
being familiar
with a lot of these
pathologies. I know like
our school, we don't get
endocrine until the
spring before boards.
So just keep in mind that
hypothyroidism,
vitamin deficiencies,
substance use, all of
these types of things
can contribute to
depressive symptoms and
mimic them in certain
circumstances as well.
So again, this is a
quick list of different
diagnostic tests that
you can run to work
up some of those items
on your differential
and rule them out before
we go ahead and make
a full psychiatric
diagnosis all right so
the main takeaway from
this slide is just to
understand some of the
pathophysiology behind
a major depressive
disorder and that is
the fact that there is
this interplay between
these three
neurotransmitters here and so
the important thing
to note is mainly for
your pharmacology
lectures moving forward to
understand that there is
this interplay between
serotonin, dopamine,
and norepinephrine.
And the medications
that we use to manage
depression, anxiety,
and other mental health
disorders will affect
different neurotransmitters.
So for example,
your selective
serotonin reuptape inhibitors
are going to affect
serotonin, right? Who
would have thought?
Another important thing
to know about this
is that when you take
brain imaging for
individuals with chronic
untreated depression,
it'll actually show
decreases in the
volume of the frontal
lobe and the hippocampus.
So there is a true
measurable effect that
we can actually detect
on brain imaging
for individuals with
untreated depression.
All right, so this is
our first big disease
that we're going to be
talking about in this
lecture, and this is
major depressive disorder.
So according to the
DSM-5 criteria, you
need to have symptoms
present for most days
over the past two
weeks. So the symptoms
need to be persisting
for a minimum period of
two weeks. They must
also impair functioning.
So if they say I'm
feeling a bit more sad
than usual, I'm sleeping
more, I gained weight,
but it does not impair
their functioning,
then by definition it
can't be a disorder.
And then additionally
we also need to
account for the fact
that no other illness or
substance use could be
causing the symptoms
that they're having.
So you want to rule
out those medical
diagnoses and substances
first, like we talked
about previously.
All right, and here's
some epidemiologic
factors that we
can talk about.
In terms of U.S.
lifetime prevalence of
major depressive
disorder, it's about 17%,
which is pretty huge
when you think about
it. Imagine walking on
the street in New York
and you say, you know,
one in five of these
people is suffering
with a pretty severe
mental health disorder.
So this is why we
always talk about always
having empathy for
everybody that we interact
with, right? Because
you never know what
anybody else is going
through at any point
in their life. And
they may have a brave
face on, but it's really
important to kind of
take a step back, put
yourself in other
people's shoes, and
understand that what other
people are going through
might not immediately
be evident to us.
There are differences
in the age of onset.
So for unipolar
depressive disorders it's
anywhere from 20 to
40 years old but for
psychotic depression
it's about 50 to 70 years
old and again this is
just some epidemiology
for your own education
to kind of show
the prevalence of these
diseases in society
so also in line with
the dsm-5 criteria we
need five or more of
the following symptoms
now this is a lot
to just memorize all
on its own so on the
next slide i'm going
to show you a little
mnemonic that i like
that's also in first
aid that will help
you guys compartmentalize
and understand
all of the
potential symptoms
that someone with
major depressive
disorder might
present with
so that mnemonic is
sig e caps and each
first letter of these
symptoms here is going
to be in mnemonic and
remember we need at
least five of these
according to the dsm-5
criteria so let's talk
about them sleep just
stands for different
changes in sleep
patterns it could be
insomnia or it could be
excessive sleeping
interest aka anhedonia is
going to be the loss
of interest or pleasure
in activities that
they previously enjoyed
meanwhile guilt
encompasses feelings of
guilt or worthlessness
in terms of energy
there's decreased
energy levels or fatigue
for concentration
perhaps difficulty
concentrating or making
decisions decision fatigue
can be a really big
part of this as well
here we have appetite
so changes in appetite
either increased or
decreased psychomotor
stands for different
types of agitation or
feeling like you're
slowing down to a crawl
and you're unable to
really focus or dial
in on anything during
the day and last but
least is suicide so
thoughts or attempts at
suicide also constitutes
one of these symptoms
so keep in mind really
good mnemonic to
try and summarize all
these symptoms and
remember we need at
least five of these okay
so how do we screen
for a depression in a
clinical setting well
here we have the phq2
so the patient health
questionnaire 2. this
is a very very simple
thing that you can do
on all of your patients
whether you're in
primary care or someone's
just coming into an
urgent care clinic
it's a very quick and
easy thing that you
can just ask during the
patient intake or during
that initial interview
and it only has two
questions so really
you ask the patient
over the last two weeks
have you been
bothered by any of the
following problems and
then you'd say little
interest or pleasure
in doing things so that
would be screening for
anhedonia or feeling
down, depressed, or
hopeless. And you can
see the scale goes up
by increments of one,
so not at all would
be zeros, several days
during those two weeks
would be ones, more
than half the days, et
cetera, et cetera. The
important thing to note
here is your cutoff
score is greater than
or equal to three.
If that is the
case, then you have
a positive
screening test for
the potential of
major depressive
disorder. It does
not confirm it,
but it shows you
that you might
have the potential
for that.
So now let's say a
patient screens positively
for major depressive
disorder on the
PHQ-2. What's the next
step? Now we do the
PHQ-9, which is just
a longer survey that
the patient can fill
out and gives us a
more detailed interpretation
of the symptoms
that they could
currently be feeling.
All right, so we
talked about diagnosis.
We talked about a
little bit of the
epidemiology. Now we're
going to go into talking
about how do we treat
major depressive
disorder. So there's
a bunch of different
medications and a
bunch of different
types of therapy. So
because you're going to
get a big overview
about all these
medications in your
dedicated farm lectures,
you won't go too in
depth about them now.
So just take what we're
saying here, a little
grain of salt, you'll
get this in more
detail later on. But
basically, you have
three main classes of
drugs that we like to
use that are first
line. You have your
selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitors, which
are going to only act
on serotonin. And it
does this by inhibiting
the reuptake of
serotonin by the nerve
cells and allowing it
to stay in the synaptic
cleft for longer.
If it stays there longer,
then you have more
potential for them to
continue to bind to
receptors on the
adjacent cells, which can
modify some of those
depressive symptoms
and hopefully get them
to go away entirely.
With SNRIs, these
are serotonin and
norepinephrine reuptake
inhibitors. So these are
going to work on two
neurotransmitters,
serotonin and
norepinephrine. And last but
not least, you also
have your NRIs, which
are your norepinephrine
reuptake inhibitors.
These are things
like bupropion. Also,
you may have heard
it called Welbutrin,
right? An important
thing to know about
the NRIs is that they
are contraindicated
in individuals with
eating and seizure
disorders. And this
is because it actually
decreases the seizure
threshold. So if you
have an individual
with anorexia nervosa,
and they aren't
eating, you know, their
meals, and they have
electrolyte imbalances
as a result of
poor nutrition and
constant purging, the
NRIs could be very
detrimental to them because
they could potentiate
a seizure. So
understanding how other
comorbidities also
interact with these
medications is
important for your
future as a
clinician as well.
We're also going to
talk about some of the
different forms of
therapy. The main one
that a lot of individuals
use is CBT. It's
called Cognitive
Behavioral Therapy, and
we'll get into that
in just a little bit.
All right, so let's
talk about some of the
different types of
therapy now. And CBT,
Cognitive Behavioral
Therapy, is one of
the big ones, and
it's based on several
core principles. The first
is that psychological
problems are based
in part on faulty
or unhelpful ways
of thinking. So this
could be self
-deprecation, it could be
learned helplessness,
whatever the case,
it postulates that
all your psychological
problems really are
going to form from
unhelpful or potentially
detrimental ways
of thinking about
the world around you.
Psychological problems
are based also in
part on learned
patterns of unhelpful
behavior so that's the
second core principle
of cbt all right
and from people
suffering from psychological
problems the the
main goal of cbt
is to try and teach
them better ways of
coping with that stress
and those problems
to hopefully relieve
the symptoms at their
core rather than
need to rely on some
sort of medication
forever. Now, is that
a bad thing if you
need to take your
SSRI for the rest
of your life? No, of
course not. They're
so benign and the
doses are so small
that it really isn't
that big of a deal.
But in many cases, you
might have an individual
that goes through
therapy and now they
are feeling significantly
better about their
mental health overall.
So it's really important
to emphasize this with
patients that, you
know, the medications
are good and they can
help but if we want
to get to the root of
their problems therapy
is going to be a very
important and sometimes
even necessary adjunct
so what happens if we
have severe treatment
resistant depression
maybe they failed
multiple medications
maybe cbt or other types
of thought talk therapy
are just like not
really working and so
you need something that's
rapid we could try
something called ect so
ect stands for
electroconvulsive therapy
and it is an extremely
rapid acting method for
treating refractory
depression it can also
manage psychotic symptoms
catatonia and acute
suicidality it does
this and it sounds a
little bit scary but it
does this by inducing
tonic-clonic seizures
under anesthesia with
a neuromuscular blockade
some of the adverse
effects include
disorientation, headache,
anterograde or retrograde
amnesia that are
usually going to
resolve in six months.
And there are no absolute
contraindications.
So in a severely
depressed pregnant
individual or older
adult with comorbidities
that might have other
health issues, this
could still be done.
And really, this is
saved for severe refractory
cases of depression
in which the
individual is a danger
to themselves or others,
and we really need
a rapid acting method.
Not every hospital
or psychiatrist is
going to have ECT on
deck. It's a very
highly specialized form
of therapy, but it
can be very effective.
All right, so another
type of therapy that
we can use is called
transcranial magnetic
stimulation, aka TMS.
And rather than using
electricity, this uses
magnetic fields to
directly stimulate
nerve cells in the brain
to try and improve
mood and cognition for
treatment-resistant
depression. The main benefit
of TMS is that it's a
non-invasive procedure
that patients can
drive themselves to
and from. So it's only
about 30 to 40-minute
sessions, does not
require any anesthesia.
But the issues with
TMS is that there are
some contraindications,
including a history
of seizures or epilepsy,
as this treatment
can potentially decrease
the seizure threshold,
as well as any
intracranial electronic
implants or anything
metallic or magnetic
hardware all right
so before we continue
and this might seem a
little jarring to just
transition from
depression to bipolar and
back and forth between
the two but it's really
important to understand
this aspect of
medical diagnosis
because this is how you
work up a true depression
case in the clinic
so why is it so important
that we actually
rule out bipolar
disorder first before
defaulting to a diagnosis
of major depressive
disorder and the reason
for that lies in the
pharmacology so most
antidepressants when
they're prescribed first
can actually worsen
the manic and hypomanic
episodes that are
found in bipolar
disorder so a big example
of this is when
you give ssris as a
monotherapy if you
misdiagnose your patient with
depression and they
had bipolar disorder,
it can worsen or
induce a manic episode,
leading to extreme
distress for the patient.
However, you can combine
mood stabilizers and
an SSRI under physician
supervision. So
again, just a quick
little clinical pearl is
going to make more sense
when we go deeper into
bipolar disorder,
but it's important to
bring this up now as
we continue to work up
our two cases with major
depressive disorder.
So how do we rule out
that the patient has
bipolar disorder before
we make a diagnosis
of depression? Well,
again, we have additional
questionnaires and
screening, right? So
the best tool for screening
bipolar 1 disorder
is going to be the mood
disorder questionnaire.
Just a bunch of yes
and no's that can
eventually be scored and
give you an indication
of whether or not
there is the potential
for your patient
to have bipolar
disorder remember
this is a
screening tool it
is not diagnostic
but back to our cases
let's say that we are
getting a little bit
more information from
both luffy and nami
and so here are some of
their test results
and a further history
that we got from both
of them both of their
mood disorder questionnaires
were negative for
any previous hypomanic
or manic episodes
again we're going to
talk about that more in
a little bit later
on the lecture all uh
for these lab results
all values were within
normal limits and there
was no recent loss
or remarkable change in
their lives all right
so based on the clinical
picture presented
what diagnosis do both
luffy and nami have
now let's take a step
back and let's think
both luffy and nami
had at least five of
those sigi caps
symptoms they note that
their symptoms have
been affecting their
daily life their
quality of life and
they've been experiencing
these symptoms most
days for at least
two weeks right so
keeping all of that in
mind what do we think
that the answer
could be and if you
guess c you're 100
correct they are both
suffering from major
depressive disorder.
All right, so
another quick
question for you guys.
True or false?
Asking about
suicide puts the
idea in the
patient's mind.
And the answer to
this is false, right?
Asking about suicide,
suicidal thoughts does
not increase suicidal
thoughts. And we want
to ask whether or not
the patient is currently
suicidal, both for
the patient's safety
but also because it
can help us with our
treatment. If we say I
am extremely suicidal,
I'm going to go home,
I'm going to hurt
myself, then we know
that this is a very ill
patient that potentially
needs to be admitted,
right? So keep in
mind that about 21% of
patients with recurrent
depressive disorder
will attempt suicide.
Again, that's one in
five. That's a really
big chunk. And so
it's important to remember
these risk factors
for suicide with the
mnemonic sad persons.
All right, so here
are some of those risk
factors for suicide
death as we talked about
before, and here's your
mnemonic sad persons.
So starting with the
first letter, it refers
to the *** of the
patient. So males are
more likely to die
from suicide death than
females. Now while it
is true that women, in
terms of statistics,
may try more often, men
will actually follow
through and accomplish
their goal more often
and this is due to the
methods that individuals
use so males tend to
use more violent
methods females are less
violent the main thing
to keep in mind is that
men tend to go out
more often through
firearms use and again
some of this stuff may be
a bit triggering but
just try to bear with
me through this as these
are really important
risk factors to keep
in mind to give your
patients the most
comprehensive care possible
so again *** is a
pretty big determinant.
Age, so young
adults or older
adults tend to
be more likely
to succeed in
their attempts.
Long-term depression
is a big risk factor.
But the highest risk
factor is actually a
previous attempt. So
let's say that you have
a male who is older,
they're like 62 years
old, they've been
depressed their whole
life, and they have,
you know, two previous
suicide attempts. and
the question is asking
you, you know, what
is the highest risk
factor for suicide in
this patient, this is
always going to be
your answer. So you see
that on your USMLE,
your Comlex, or your
school exams. Keep that
in mind that previous
attempts, again, are
the highest predictor,
highest risk factor
for suicide death.
Ethanol or drug use,
this is important
because it impairs
rational thinking. It
can potentially lead
to psychosis, so
********* use, ***,
*******, any type of
drug that could affect
cognition or the
individual's perception
of the world around
them, it's going to
be a risk factor.
Sickness, so like
a medical illness,
let's say the
patient has, you
know, cancer in
their terminal, that
is a pretty big
risk factor as well.
Here we have an
organized plan. So if the
patient comes to you
telling you that, you
know, I'm going to
go and take all of my
medication all at once
tonight and then just go
to sleep, you know
that they have an
organized plan that is
a big problem if there's
no spouse or other
social support at home
so let's say they live
alone or all their
family members you know
have passed they don't
really have any friends
that's a big risk
factor and then again
stated future intent
this kind of goes along
with the organized
plan but it's different
in that they may not
have that plan yet
but they say that oh
I'm going to go home
I'm going to formulate
something I do plan
on doing this okay um
there are some protective
factors um like
effective care for
comorbidities like those
medical illnesses that
we talked about um if
you did have family
community connectedness
you had a good social
support network that's
protective as well
individuals with
stronger cultural and
religious beliefs that
encourage self
-preservation also is
protective and then more
strong problem-solving
skills. Again, those
ones are less tested
for whatever reason.
They like to look
at the risk factors,
but it's good to keep
in mind the protective
factors as well.
All right, so for
some of our subsets of
depression, we're going
to get into a bunch of
different disorders now.
The first is persistent
depressive disorder.
So this is defined
by depressed mood for
at least two years,
right? That's a stark
contrast of major
depressive disorder, which
is going to require you
to have symptoms for
at least two weeks.
This also used to be
called dysthymia. So you
might sometimes see
it mentioned like that
in older textbooks or
materials. It's often
more mild than major
depressive disorder. And
because of this, you
only need greater than
or equal to two
depressive symptoms, those
CIGI-CAP symptoms that
last greater than or
equal to two years. If
it's in children, it's
greater than or equal
to one year. The last
qualifying factor of
this disease is that
any remission in symptoms,
depressive symptoms,
should last less
than or equal to two
months. So to treat
it, we use our standard
major depressive disorder
therapies, as well
as ECT or TMS for
treatment-resistant cases.
There's also MDD with
seasonal pattern. So
the easiest way to
think about this is I
hear it all the time
everyone's like oh my
gosh this stinks that
i go home and it's
pitch black by five
o'clock right and i
empathize with that it's
a bit depressing but
imagine um it hits you
a bit more than just
being sad or upset and
missing the daylight
let's say you have
major depressive
episodes that are
occurring only during a
particular season in
this case usually the
winter time it could
also be in other climates
let's say there's a
rainy season where
it's constantly mucky
and dark and gross out,
that could also
contribute to it, right?
So this is really
environmentally driven.
And so in order to
diagnose somebody with
MDD with seasonal
pattern, they need to
have these symptoms
only during a
particular season for
greater than or equal
to two consecutive
years, and in most of
their years across
their lifetime, okay?
Atypical symptoms are
also common and we'll
talk about those in
the next slide but in
order to treat this it
would be your standard
major depressive disorder
therapies as well
as light therapy
because again this is
environmental right so
in the absence of natural
lights it is exacerbating
these symptoms
that the individuals
are currently feeling
all right so for our
next disorder that
we're going to talk
about here we have
depression with atypical
features so i promise
you guys we'll talk
about some of those
atypical symptoms So
let's jump into it.
The depression atypical
features is characterized
by a couple of
different things. The
first aspect of it is
called mood reactivity.
So this is transient
improvement in
response to a positive
event. And so this is
going to be something
like, okay, your patient
is depressed, and then
their child, let's
say, is going to be
getting married. and so
they have a remission
of their symptoms
improved mood during
those wedding festivities
everything is great
it's a positive time
and then they go back
to the real world get
back in their routine
and those depression
symptoms start to come
back there may also
be hypersomnia and
hyperphagia as well as
something called leaden
paralysis which is
just this heavy feeling
in the arms and legs
there could also be
something called long
-standing interpersonal
rejection sensitivity
and that's just a fancy
way of saying that
these individuals are
really anxious about
being rejected so it
could be like oh i'm
applying for this
promotion at my job i'm so
anxious that they're
not going to like me
and it's not so much just
anxiety or nervousness
it's more debilitating
gets in the way
of them doing what
they need to do so like
imagine every time
you are going to ask
somebody out on a date
you got this terrible
feeling of anxiety um
this overwhelming feeling
of dread and this
anxious feeling like
that you were going to
be rejected and that
you're not going to
be accepted and and a
lot of self-deprecation
that goes along with
that so this is the
most common subtype of
depression and it's
really interesting because
it emphasizes the
fact that we need to
have a broader net in
our mental heuristics
when thinking about
psychiatric illnesses.
Not everything is
going to present as cut
and dry with those
CIGICAP symptoms. You also
need to look at and
identify these atypical
features in your
patients moving forward.
So treatment for this,
CBT and SSRIs, like
with major depressive
disorder, and you may
also use monoamine
oxidase inhibitors,
MAO inhibitors. These
are effective, but
they're not really first
line as they have more
severe side effect
profiles when
compared to the other
contemporary medications
that we tend to use.
Another one I want
to talk about on
this slide is substance
and medication
-induced depressive
disorder. It's exactly
what it sounds like.
It's a depressive
disorder induced
by substance use.
This could be alcohol,
opiates, *******,
amphetamines,
steroids, etc., etc.
These symptoms are
going to develop soon
after intoxication
or withdrawal from
that medication.
Then treatment,
consequently, is just
supportive measures and
discontinuing use
of that substance or
medication. If that
means that there's
an addiction involved,
then we can get
proper services
involved to help us
with that as well,
consult social
work, and move
forward accordingly.
All righty. And lastly,
for our subsets of
depression, this
one's also pretty self
-explanatory. We talked
about this in the beginning.
These are depressive
disorders due to
another medical
condition. Again, your
hypothyroidism, that lack
of that thyroid hormone
is going to lead to
constant downs. You're
going to have hair
thinning, weight gain,
depressed mood, all
consequences of having
decreased thyroid
hormone levels. It
could be adrenal
insufficiency as well.
Lupus can present
with depression,
vitamin B12 deficiencies,
other vitamin and
electrolyte deficiencies.
So the big thing is to
treat the underlying
medical causes. So
there's a big joke
when you guys get to
the hospital, if you
see a patient that
you might think that,
oh, they might be in
a psychotic episode
or they might be
depressed, more often than
not, they're going to
say, oh, there's too
many red values on
the lab work, go fix
those, and then you
can try and consult
psych again. So do your
due diligence to try
and work out all
the other potential
medical causes before we
default to a psychiatric
illness. Because if
it is from another
medical cause, it's
curative. Once you
fix the underlying
medical cause, you're
going to fix the
depressive symptoms. Okay.
So this next slide is
going to be all about
peripartum mood
disturbances. So these all
occur with onset during
pregnancy or within
four weeks of delivery.
And there is an
increased risk for those
individuals' histories
of mood disorders,
so either depression
or bipolar disorders.
And so the first one
that we're going to
talk about is very
common. This is just the
postpartum blues, and
it has about a 50 to
85% incidence rate.
It's characterized
by your depressed
affect, tearfulness,
fatigue, that starts two
to three days after
delivery, and it
usually resolves within
two weeks. So treatment
for this is going
to be supportive,
making sure the new mom
is happy and healthy
and not overwhelmed
with a lot of the
stresses of motherhood
that comes along after
delivery. So supportive
care and then recurrent
follow-ups to assess
for possible MDD with
peripartum onset, which
is our next disorder
that we're going to
talk about. This is
only 10 to 15% incidence
rate, and this was
formally called
postpartum depression. So
this meets the major
depressive disorder criteria
with an onset either
during pregnancy or
within four weeks
after delivery. So if
those postpartum blues
continue beyond two
weeks, then we know that
we could potentially
have major depressive
disorder with peripartum
onset. And with this,
we want to look at
CBT and SSRIs as our
first-line treatments.
So some other mood
disorders that could
potentially affect
individuals. There's
first one is premenstrual
dysphoric disorder,
and this is marked
by behavioral and
mood symptoms that
begin the week before
the start of the
menstrual cycle and the
end within the first
few days of menses,
okay? So this is
postulated to be
hormonally driven.
So for the diagnosis,
you need at least
five symptoms total,
including one or
more mood symptoms,
okay? So these
could be feelings of
anxiety, irritability,
and tension,
sadness or despair,
changes in appetite,
mood swings, panic
attacks, frequent crying,
sleep issues, low energy,
trouble thinking
or focusing,
bloating, breast
tenderness, muscle pain.
All of these symptoms
are fair game. And
you'll learn a lot more
about this when you do
OB-GYN in that last
semester before boards.
I just want to give it
to you guys ahead of
time so you see it
and it's not something
brand new to you, and
it also fits into the
subject matter that we're
talking about today.
So treatments for this
is your SSRIs. These
are going to be your
first-line treatments.
Oral contraceptives
can also aid with
some of the hormonal
and mood symptoms as
well and may pair
as a good adjunct,
especially if there's
also dysmenorrhea,
so a lot of pain with
menstruation, heavy
menstrual cycles,
lifestyle changes
like regular exercise,
stress management,
limiting caffeine and
alcohol use, as well
as GNRH agonists for
severe cases. Again,
that's another hormone
modulating therapy.
So here are some of
the symptoms that we
were talking about
before. And again, this
is not an exhaustive
list. There can be
variations in mood
and constitutional
symptoms that are
experienced by these
individuals. But again,
you might have these
mood swings,
irritability or anger,
depressed mood, and
hopelessness. And the other
symptoms would be
your anhedonia,
difficulty concentrating,
low energy fatigue,
as well as those
physical symptoms
we talked about too,
breast tenderness,
bloating, joint
muscle pain, etc.
So next we have disruptive
mood dysregulation
disorder. And this
is a severe chronic
irritability in children
that includes frequent
temper outbursts plus
persistent irritable
mood. So the diagnosis
for this depends on
three or more severe
temper outbursts so
either verbal or
behavioral that are out of
proportion to the situation
for a few weeks so
i don't know let's say
you have a child that
has a bowl of cereal
and they're walking to
the couch watch saturday
morning cartoons
and they trip and they
fall and cereal goes
everywhere and there's
milk and they're freaking
out and now they have
this massive, severe
temper outburst that
is out of character
for that child. And
what happened? Normally,
maybe you'd be a bit
upset. They'd say,
don't cry over spilled
milk, but the child could
be screaming, crying,
hitting, punching,
completely losing their
faculties, working
themselves up so much
that maybe they pass
out, all of these
types of things, right?
So symptoms must also
occur in at least
two settings. So they
have to occur at home,
at school at a
friend's house it can't
just be symptoms
that are occurring in
one setting they must
also last at least
12 months with no
break lasting greater
than three months and
this diagnosis can only
really be made
between the ages of 6
and 18 but the onset
of symptoms must be
noted before age 10
so if you have someone
coming in and they're
16 years old and
they're just starting
with these symptoms,
it cannot qualify
for a diagnosis
of disruptive
mood dysregulation
disorder. It must
occur before age 10.
All right, so continuing
with disruptive mood
dysregulation disorder,
a quick note is
that this diagnosis
cannot, I repeat, cannot
coexist with bipolar
disorder or intermittent
explosive disorder.
But you can have
concomitant ADHD and
depression, which is why
sometimes if therapy
like cognitive behavioral
therapy or parent
management training does
not work out, you can
utilize stimulants or
SSRIs to receive a bit
more of like a measurable
effect and improvement
in the patients.
Another note is that
between outbursts,
their mood may be
persistently irritable or
angry most of the day,
nearly every day. So
that's why I got this
little angie kid right
here. He's throwing a
little temper tantrum.
All right, so that is
everything that has to
do with depression, major
depressive disorder,
and its subtypes.
Let's move on to some
additional clinical
cases and now start to
tackle some other mood
disorders. So now we
have Steve. He's a 29
-year-old male, presents
to your clinic with
his partner, and he
reports that he has
severe anger problems,
which he notes are
affecting his marriage. He's
healthy, and he's on
no medications. He
denies any current or
past drug and alcohol
use, which is corroborated
by his partner.
He's pleasant and
cooperative with good eye
contact. He easily
engages in conversation.
You interview his wife
and you learn that not
only is he irritable,
but he's also more self
-confident, starts new
projects and hobbies,
and doesn't sleep
much, talks faster, and
he wants *** all the
time for about five to
six days at a time.
These symptoms are then
followed immediately
by a period of low
mood, decreased energy,
and sleeping a lot. His
mood disorder
questionnaire was negative.
Okay, now we have one
more clinical case,
and just like with our
first two, I want you
guys to start to think
about comparing and
contrasting the two
clinical cases as we're
going through this. So
here we have Charlotte,
a 35-year-old female,
presenting to the
emergency department
via EMS. She was brought
in after her roommate
called 911, and
according to her
roommate charlotte hasn't
slept in three weeks
instead choosing to work
on a proposal that
could stop world hunger
she's also had different
****** partners
visit the apartment
every night during this
time her roommate grew
increasingly concerned
for charlotte's safety
prompting her to
call 9-1-1 in the ed
the urine tox screen is
negative and when
charlotte's family arrives
they note she frequently
cycles between
periods of intense energy
and lethargy of note
she had one inpatient
stay for attempted
suicide at age 27 and
takes no medications.
So let's think
about it. What
are some of those
key points that
we found in
these histories?
With Steve, we have
these episodic anger
problems. He was negative
for drug or alcohol
use. He had half
-finished projects, and he
cycles between high
and low energy that
lasts less than a week
at a time okay meanwhile
with charlotte she
was brought into the
hospital by emergency
medical services she's
negative for drug or
alcohol use and she
cycles between high
and low energy that
lasts greater than a
week at a time and one
previous hospitalization
and suicide attempt
all right so now that
we've taken a look
at our two cases
let's jump right
into bipolar disorders
So when talking
about bipolar disorder,
before we get into
the DSM-5 criteria
for that, we need
to talk about
something called mania.
Now mania is defined
as a distinct period
of persistently
elevated, expansive, or
irritable mood, or
increased activity and
energy that lasts for
at least one week.
And the DSM-5 lists a
ton of different symptoms
like we saw for
depression, but I got a
pretty good mnemonic on
the next one. so don't
harp on all the little
details here. The
important thing to
note is that we need at
least three or more of
the following symptoms
to be present, and it
could be four or more
if irritable mood is
also included. But let's
take a look at our
mnemonic to try and make
sense of all of these
different criteria.
All right, so that
mnemonic that I promised
you guys is dig fast,
and this is going
to help us remember
key symptoms of a
manic episode. Remember,
we need at least
three of these symptoms
and we could be
four total if the person
also has irritable
mood, okay? So
start off with D for
distractibility.
These individuals will
easily lose their
attention or jump between
tasks. Now I stands
for indiscretion or
impulsivity, all
right? So this is going
to be excessive
involvement in impulsive
or reckless behaviors,
drug use, alcohol,
unprotected ***,
things like that. For
G, you have grandiosity,
so excessive self
-esteem or self-image.
This can progress
to delusions of
grandeur, which are
more severe than just
grandiose thoughts.
F stands for
flight of ideas or
racing thoughts.
You have this rapid
flow of these
disconnected thoughts.
A stands for activity
increase or goal
-directed behavior. So
staying up all night
to read a book, do
homework, or like in
Charlotte's case,
wanting to write up a
proposal that could
solve world hunger.
Here for the
next one, we have
sleep deficit.
So because you're
constantly in this
wired state, you're
unable to sleep,
you feel tired,
you have some
insomnia, et cetera.
And then talkativeness.
So like your
pressured speech that
seemingly is unending.
Tone varies from swift
to loud to heated
and hostile. Think
of it as a more
severe version of
when if you have
like a little sibling
or little cousin,
like three or four
years old, and they're
telling you about like
their favorite TV show
or their toy, this
action figure, and, you
know, it just seems like
they're rambling and
mumbling. That would
kind of be your
talkativeness, like a real
-world example of that.
All right, so you
might have also heard
the words mania and
hypomania thrown around.
And really, look
at the prefix hypo.
That's just going
to mean that it's
a less severe form
of mania. So manic
episodes must last
at least a week.
Meanwhile,
hypomanic episodes
generally last
at least four
days, but less than
seven. So this
needs to be under
seven days for it
to be hypomania.
Another thing to note
is that regardless of
the time period of
the symptoms, if the
patient is hospitalized
for their symptoms then
it is automatically
categorized as mania
so only manic episodes
will get some individuals
admitted to a psych
unit or arrested
not hypomanic episodes
okay so if you have a
patient that comes in
they were brought in
by ems they were
hospitalized in an inpatient
unit and they've only
been experiencing
three out of those dig
fast criteria for about
two days, it still
qualifies as mania,
right? People with
hypomania are often still
functional while
hypomanic, as we saw with
the case study with
Steve. And as such,
hypomania is a bit more
difficult to diagnose.
All right, so now
that we have all that
terminology out the
way, let's jump into
differentiating between
the different types of
bipolar. So for bipolar
disorders, you could
have bipolar 1, which
only requires one
type of episode. You
must have greater than
or equal to one manic
episode with or without
a hypomanic or
depressive episode, and
they may be separated
by any length of time.
Let's compare this
to bipolar 2, which
requires two types of
episodes. You do need a
hypomanic and a
depressive episode with no
history of any manic
episodes, right? So
bipolar 1 is going to
involve mania and depressive
symptoms, while
bipolar 2 involves
hypomania and depressive
symptoms. Now, you may
have also heard of
psychothymic disorder,
which is a milder form
of bipolar disorder
that fluctuates between
mild depression and
hypomanic symptoms.
These symptoms must last
greater than or equal
to two years, with
the symptoms presenting
at least half of
that time, with any
remission lasting less than
or equal to two
months. So the way that
you pick a lot of
these things out is by
looking at the severity
of the symptoms. The
more severe symptoms
that result in
hospitalization, you're
automatically in a manic
episode, so you're at
bipolar 1. Bipolar 2 is
going to be still
hypomanic and depression
with cycling between
the two episodes, but
it's going to be a
lot less severe. And
cyclothymic disorder is
the least severe and has
the most long-term type
of chronic diagnosis
timeline, in that it
must be lasting for
at least greater than
or equal to two years.
All right, so just
like I did with the
depressive symptoms,
here's what a
potential differential
could look like. By
no means do you need
to memorize any of
this. This is just
more or less for
your reference.
We'll talk more about
schizophrenia and
schizoaffective disorders
in the next lecture
I'm going to do.
But for now, just
know that this is
kind of included in
here because a lot
of the psychotic
symptoms that you may
experience in
these disorders can
overlap or appear
similar to what mania
and hypomania symptoms
could look like.
Okay, so if you guys
were paying attention,
you might already
know the answer
to this. But true
or false, if manic
symptoms result in
hospitalization, it is
characterized as mania
and not hypomania,
regardless of the
timing of symptoms.
And if you guessed
true, you'd be correct
on this one. Remember,
hypomania, less
severe, no hospitalization,
no psychosis, lasts
at least four days,
but less than seven.
And mania is going to
be the more severe of
the two. may require
hospitalization, may
include psychosis, and
it can last at least
one week or any duration
if hospitalized.
So let's take a look
at treating, right? So
in order to treat
bipolar disorder, we rely
on second generation
antipsychotics or mood
stabilizers, okay?
And again, I won't get
too in the weeds with
the pharmacology because
a lot of this stuff
can be pretty dense.
You'll get that in your
dedicated farm lectures.
But what to know is
that the treatment
is based on what phase
of the illness the
person is in so whether
they're manic or depressed
okay so if they are
currently in acute
mania your second
generation antipsychotics
and mood stabilizers
can be given as a mono
or dual therapy so one
or the other or both
for acute depression
we can use your second
generation antipsychotics
plus an ssri or
other antidepressants
monotherapy or adjunctive
to a mood stabilizer
like lithium so that
was what we talked about
beforehand about how
you never want to give
ssris on their own
because it can actually
make these manic
symptoms worse but if
we combine them with an
antipsychotic or a mood
stabilizer it can help
with modifying and
potentially eliminating
a lot of the more severe
depressive symptoms
that can occur in
bipolar disorder, right?
Last but not least,
we would want to
definitely recommend
therapy for these
patients as well to
assist with improving
their insight into
their mental illness,
improving compliance
to medications,
and then teaching
patients really how
to better identify
their mood changes
and be aware of their
own mental health.
And so these are some
summary slides coming
up. I won't read
through all of them.
These are by all means
not all inclusive but
they synthesize the
information very well
so when you guys are
coming back to review
this lecture you guys
can take a look at
all of these little
snippets or use them
when you're making your
flashcards here are
all the references
in case you guys want
to dive any deeper into
the information again
i love first aid
this should be your
holy bible it has really
good um short form
articles and tables that
you can read that'll
help you really
synthesize the information
the DSM-5 itself
is always a great
primary source but it's
a bit dense and then
dirty medicine on
YouTube has a bunch of
really great videos
going over a lot of the
finer details and the
high yield test taking
materials so hopefully
you guys enjoyed
here is the feedback
form and I'll catch
you guys in the next
lecture all right bye